hey this is presh talwalkar
a group of 10 rabbits enjoys racing
against each other but the group also
has a friendly spirit
the rabbits plan races so that each
rabbit beats every other rabbit
rabbit a is said to beat rabbit b
if rabbit a finishes at least one spot
ahead of rabbit b in some race
rabbit a does not have to win the race
it only has to finish ahead of rabbit b
in some race
a simple solution is the group plans 10
races where each rabbit finishes first
in a different race
but is there a more efficient method
what is the minimum number of races so
that each rabbit can claim to beat every
other rabbit
for the minimum number how many
different ways can they plan the
races
and what if there are n rabbits
how many races are needed and how many
ways can they plan the races
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
so somewhat surprisingly the rabbits
only need to plan two races
let's number the rabbits from 1 to 10
and let's write the finishing order of
the race as a b c and so on to mean a
finishes in last place then b finishes
then c finishes and so on
in the first race we'll put the rabbits
in sequential order where rabbit 10
beats all of the other rabbits
rabbit 9 beats all of the rabbits except
for 10 rabbit 8 beats all of the rabbits
except for 10 and 9 and so on until
rabbit one beats no one
so now each rabbit is beating all of the
numbers that are less than that rabbit's
number
in the next race what we'll do is we'll
have the rabbits finish in exactly the
reverse order
now in this race it's the opposite
each rabbit beats all of the rabbits
whose numbers are higher than the
rabbit's number so rabbit one beats all
of the other rabbits rabbit two beats
all of the rabbits except for one rabbit
three beats all of the rabbits except
for one and two and so on until rabbit
10 beats no one
you can check that together
with these two races each rabbit can
claim to have beaten all of the other
rabbits
this demonstrates that two is a possible
solution
furthermore it shows that 2 is the
minimum number
we know that one race cannot suffice
because in that first race there will be
a rabbit who finishes in last place who
doesn't beat anyone else
so 2 is the minimum number and it is
achieved
so how many different ways can they plan
these races
well in this solution i put the rabbits
in order from one to ten
but the first race can actually be any
arrangement of the numbers from one to
ten
it can be any permutation of the numbers
from one to ten and the second race just
has the same numbers in reverse order
you can check that that solution works
so how many different ways are there for
this
well the first race can be any
permutation
and there are 10 factorial ways to
arrange 10 different rabbits
so there are 10 factorial ways
the problem generalizes to n rabbits
we once again only need two races
the first race will have the rabbits
going in order from one to n and the
second race can be the reverse order
but in fact the first race could be any
permutation of the numbers one to n and
the second race would be the reverse
order
how many ways are there to order the
numbers one n there are n factorial
permutations and that's the number of
ways
that they could plan the races to have
the minimum number of races
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch my
blog mind your decisions that you can
follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description